hello
my name is cameron davidson pilon i'm
here talking to you at pi data 2020 i
have my
pi data t let's talk about life lines
so lifelines it's a survival analysis
library
written in pure python i've been
maintaining it for about five years now
and i want to give you the lifelines in
2020 and beyond
speech so the past couple years
lifelines has gone through
what i call the differential
or automatic differentiation revolution
if you don't know about automatic
differentiation or ad
it's this really cool piece of
technology that sort of came out of the
neural net libraries like tensorflow and
pi torch
but we can use that piece and a lot of
statistical models so
it enables new brand new statistical
models easy to implement
it enables just faster computations and
less time
both on the user side the developer side
to implement new ideas
it's really really cool so like this
meme says
you can almost insert differentiate
anything it's it's just awesome check it
out
automatic differentiation so lifelines
uses that now
uh lifelines also has a very fast
cadence a release cadence
so we're releasing maybe every two to
three weeks
um you can see here that we're releasing
like really really fast so always be
updating lifelines if you're a user of
it
if you haven't touched lifelines in a
couple years uh definitely upgrade
the api is pretty stable but there's new
additions and new bug fixes
as we release
lifelines tries to codify the best
survival analysis practices
so survivor analysis is a very
traditional
field it's been around for a long time
it's very traditional
and kind of the modern thinking is
about you know 10 15 years ahead of
what's happening in practice
so for example the log rank test you may
have heard of it
it's not really considered a good
practice anymore to use the log rank
test
even though everyone does it and if you
do it that's okay
but there's better solutions now and so
lifelines tries to guide you to
choose the best statistical practice
we also want to implement some of the
the newer modern practices
so this past summer the statistician
frank carol and co
they published this really cool paper on
survival calibration so really useful
for
useful for validating your models
especially predictive models
this paper came out on june 16 2020
the next day actually i had this
implemented in lifelines and ready to go
in a pr
um for for the next release so we want
to be
we want to be on the forefront of the
best practices this is a great paper
really cool paper
it's now on lifelines feel free to use
it
i'm also looking for help with lifelines
um
there's only so much i can do and
there's some just some
software things and stats things i'm
just not very good at
so in particular i'd like help with a
better integration with scikit-learn
so right now we have this wrapper around
lifelines that integrates with
scikit-learn but it's a very janky
wrapper
it's not really well implemented
um i think to work on this you probably
need a background
definitely with psychic learn some
experience with with classes and apis
um and maybe meta classes so help with
that would be appreciated
uh a better api for creating time very
data
time varying data sets is useful
survival analysis
can incorporate time varying data sets
but to go from all this time varying
data
and different tables to a pandas data
frame that
lifelines will accept that's a very
clunky process
i'd like a better way to go from raw
data to a time-varying data set
it's probably even an external library
that needs to be created that many
libraries
can use um so just help with with
managing that
or building uh building tools for for
creating time varying data sets and
finally
just a better integration with other
data libraries in the the pi data
ecosystem
so integrations for example with desk
and xray
right now lifelines has minimal support
for these for these libraries
um it shouldn't be too hard to for
example
accept x array data sets um
das might be more complicated but i'd
love to get help on on
these and kind of bring lifelines deeper
into the
pi data stack anyways if you have
questions
uh my email is online it's all over
lifelines uh but do check out the
library happy to answer questions happy
to help onboard users
and new developers anyways thanks enjoy
pi data 2020
bye everyone